So Charles, how would we go about trying to figure this out?
>> How would we go about trying to figure this out?
>> Yeah, what do you think? Which one
would you choose and how would you choose?
>> so, well that's a good question. Well
just given what you, what you've given me, I'm
going to ask. I think smartly guess, that
probably k equals 3, is the right one, and
>> K equals 3
>> And I'll tell you why.
It's because zero, one and two seem to make quite a few errors.
>> Mh-hm
>> Three does a pretty good job but doesn't, doesn't over commit to the data.
>> Hm.
>> And that's the problem with eight, is that
eight says, you know, the training data that I have
is exactly right and I should been and moved
heaven and earth in order to, to match the data.
And that's probably the wrong thing, certainly if there's any
noise or, or anything else going on in the data.
>> Right. So it sort of seems like it's overkill,
especially that it's doing these crazy things between the points. Whereas
the cubic one, even though it clings pretty close to the
points, it stays between the points, kind of between the points.
>> Yeah.
>> Which seems like a really smart thing. So yeah so, so that
turns out to be the right answer but let's actually let's actually evaluate
that more concretely.